Brian Wynn horse ESPN senior NBA writer
kind enough to join us he'll be part of
the jump and ESPN news information
platforms covering the NBA in the return
here closely and Brian joins us are you
going to the bubble Brian I don't think
so but the reason I have to say don't
think is because they haven't announced
the media rules yet not that that's a
big priority but we don't know we don't
know what the law of the land is going
to be we have to hear about it
what are your what you do you have a
like a singular biggest concern here
going into this and what they're trying
to pull off yeah I have to one is that
and my guess is it would be a star
player but it could be anybody is that
somebody comes down with the virus and
the players just lose confidence in the
entire thing and whether there's an
outbreak or not they say I don't want to
do this anymore and they defect
the other concern I have is of a genuine
outbreak where you know there's a lag
time as much as the NBA is doing here
and they are doing everything just about
everything that we know to do is that
they're there they miss it somebody gets
sick and infects five or six other
people and it's an outbreak to the point
where not only do you have to shut it
down but it becomes unclear whether
you're going to be able to restart and
again any time in your future that I
think would be a worst-case there
how many named players have you heard
from off the record that might not go I
guess it depends on your definition the
word name players from my read on folks
everyone is ready to go okay whether
they're going to be ready to go in in a
month when this actually starts a
different question
you know yesterday the Toronto Raptors
left to go to Florida to begin this
because you know issues with Canada US
border crossings they had to leave early
and if they make it back to the finals
that's a long shot but if they make it
back to the final damn they wouldn't be
back home until October October
that means they left yesterday it's a
possibility they would not be
until the fall explain what the deadline
means tomorrow so the players have until
tomorrow to raise their hands and say
I'm not going but that I'm going to tell
you I'm going to be going to be honest
though the NBA is changing the rules all
the time it's not like we have a 15 year
history of this playbook working if
somebody says they decide they don't
want to play in three weeks do I think
the NBA is going to like put them in
shackles and force them into into an
airplane no I do not but the reason that
they have to tell the teams now is that
for the next week starting at noon today
a transaction window opens that you can
sign for place and players and if you
want to be able to replace a player
who's either injured or who's you know
doesn't want to go or have some fun over
the Qatar concern you have to do within
the next seven days so that's why this
window opens by today's deadline yeah
I'm just I'm curious about the rosters
size here - Brian we're seeing with
Major League Baseball that they're going
to have to expand the rosters you know
just in case or when it happens that
somebody test positive how much of a
talent pool will these NBA teams have to
draw from not much you know
most NBA seasons have to finally players
kind of like having options on a
baseball contract you can call the guys
up a certain amount of time so they kind
of add those two guys there's a there's
a few guys kicking around out there who
are free agents who may be decent
additions but you know you lose a
starting line player you're not going to
replace them with the starting line
player you're going to replace them with
a warm body and I think one of the
concerns here is remember they're going
to play three weeks of these regular
season games before the playoffs start
if you're in ninth or tenth place and
you lose the first two or three games
and you're out of it and you're still
faced with being in that bubble for
another two weeks are you just going to
say forget
I'm going home and because the NBA is
not stopping anybody from leaving now if
you want to come back now we have a
problem but if you leave they're not
going to say stop and so that's a bit of
a concern what happens to that group of
players in the offing because you are
going to be committed to being there for
five or six weeks there's two and a half
or three weeks of training camp then
these eight games you know over the
course of two and a half three weeks you
may be tired of being there if you're a
ninth place have no chance of advancing
you're not doing a good job of dressing
this up Ryan you got a sneaky team so
the team that has underperformed all
year long has been the philly 76ers and
nobody can figure out why they would be
29 and 2 at home because i'm gonna tell
you something to be 29 and 2 at home you
got to be a damn good team and you look
at their roster and you know that their
talent doesn't is that they fit together
but there's some really good players
there and they're like below fighting
like 13 or 15 on the road and 29 and 2
at home ok well guess what they don't
have to play it'll get to play home
games anymore that's a disadvantage but
that is a good team and if they could
align together and hit their you know
hit some sort of stride they could
really be dangerous the other thing I
want to see is what the hell happens of
nickel a yogic somewhere my guess is
forty to fifty pounds when I saw him
last year I was over in China for the
World Cup he was playing on the Serbian
team he was not interested at all in
that can being in condition I would say
from last summer I would guess he's down
60 to 70 pounds I have no idea what he's
going to look like that's a huge
question mark to me yeah but Marc Gasol
looks like he's on the same diet Marc
Gasol has been losing weight steadily
over the last five years and Marc Gasol
is not the number one player on a team
but you know on that team Niccolo coach
is a first-team all-nba player who just
lost 40 pounds in three months will that
make him
an MVP candidate or will that make him
something else I mean I think it's one
of the most fascinating things I want to
see I want I'm gonna be watching the
Nugget scrimmage games but they're gonna
have in a couple of weeks maybe you
could you write up a story on the joke
is diet we find out what that workout
regimen is because I could probably
Institute that here on my show I've got
it here he hasn't given an interview yet
not only that though I'm gonna tell you
he was just photographed last week
hanging out with the Joker know that
jungle boy over in Serbia well choke a
[ __ ] is dead coronavirus out today then
the day all the players are being tested
okay now now Yogesh would have just come
back in the country and you know would
have would it be 40 if you wondered some
odd guys are being tested by today now
last week we saw the NFL they said they
tested 200 people I'll take them at
their word and 11 tested positive I did
not go to harbor but I think that's 5%
if you have 300 NBA players testing and
let's just say it's roughly the same
rate around 5% you're gonna have you
know 15 to 20 a number who are test
positive and here's something that the
NBA has not articulated very well if I
was a skeptical guy would say it's on
purpose but I can't say that if you tell
be positive under their rules 14 days no
exercise not 14 then I support eeen days
in your bed
and then you've got negative twice and
24 hours until the question I'm going to
have is if a bunch of guys here today
test positive or asymptomatic and are
asymptomatic in a week that's going to
become an issue they're going okay let
me get on the court they're like no 14
days sir and so that's going to be
interesting and you know well while
teens haven't announced the players who
have tested positive in the past for
HIPAA reasons it's going to become
pretty apparent if you don't see your
team
back up shooting guard for ten days
you're going to know that you come down
with it so I don't know how that's all
going to work when you understand that
some of these guys are going to say I
don't feel sick it's going to be an
issue
he's Brian Wynn horse ESPN's senior NBA
writer the Lakers reportedly working out
at a billionaires hauntin web what do we
know about this story here Brian this
guy Steve Jackson he I think he sold the
company long time ago he but he founded
la gear you remember LA yeah yeah Shaq
had la gear deal he built a gym on his
property in bel-air and he made a
replica of the Staples Center the court
is the exact same Court except instead
of saying Staples Center in the same
penciling it says Jackson center
he's got photos all over the walls of
teams that have come there and players
have come there throughout the years and
worked out it's in a gated community
when I went there I had to go through
the gate and he comes out and hangs out
with the players as they did there's a
commercial film there over the years
teams have used that to shoot around
it's basically been a sort of a secret
underground NBA hub and you know I'm
sure it's been available to many players
and that's the thing and one of the
reasons why these NBA players were not
coming to work out of gene facility is
because they're to follow all of these
rules that the NBA put down whereas if
they go to another place a run that they
can get a private gym they can do
whatever they feel it's necessary to
keep themselves safe and so that's why I
think today's testing but you know
they'll take a few days for it to come
back who knows when they'll actually
announce it if they ever will that's why
I think today's test is going to be very
interesting we're going to have guys who
don't think they're sick or if you'll
find wind up coming up on one other item
has to do with Knicks so it's not a
playoff team but it does have to do with
the Bucks Jason Kidd given permission by
the Lakers to interview for the Knicks
job and then you know the possibility of
bringing in the Greek freak what do you
make of this with Jay kid and the Knicks
well look the Knicks have a long way to
go before they could even think about
getting any free agent and you know
Yanis has the opportunity to summer to
extend for you know we'll see how it
happens with the salary gap and for more
than two hundred million but I will say
that I think Jason Kidd and Jim Dolan
have a really good relationship and
Jason has been interested in going back
there remember he played there one year
at the end of his career and was a
transformational stay here so I still
think it's time to another job but I
think the Knicks could do a lot to help
themselves with free agents that is
outside of some coach they have a
connection to they have done a horrible
job for the last ten years on this their
decisions specifically Jim Jones
decisions in the last month or six weeks
have been very damaging if anybody
thinks that they're going to fix that by
just hiring a coach who happens to know
a star player that's a little about you
can the commit to the Commissioner have
any power over that franchise right he's
tried he's tried he has gone to people
in the franchise I mean I don't think he
made whatever admit to this but because
it's you know not it's not sort of
deemed fair but he has gone to people in
the franchise and said what can the NBA
do to help the Knicks and the thing
about Jim Dolan you know the more people
I talk to have worked for Jim going a
lot of them really like him but Jim
Dolan has a blind spot and that he's got
horrible judgment and he's over the
years hired people to help him with that
judgment but he doesn't listen to him
and so you can't help a guy who won't
help himself David Stern tried David
Stern got him to hire Donnie Walsh David
Stern tried to get to hire other people
and make moves Adam Silver has tried it
can't force the guy into making good
decisions you could only help them he
won't accept the help you have somebody
hire advisers to help you and then you
don't listen to the advisers that you're
I mean it's crazy
didn't-didn't David Stern helped the
Knicks once where he fixed the lottery
so they could get Patrick
I mean that's what we need to do not
joking I'm joking he's up in heaven
yelling at me right now let me tell you
something I don't know what happened
back then but I can tell you last year
when the Lakers and Knicks were in the
lottery the same final four to get Jah
Zion and they held up three and four and
New Orleans in Memphis ended up one and
two all lottery that's conspiracy
theories guy that night I would say
right now yes and and I all boy if you
ever wanted to get Commissioner Stern
going who do not bring up that lottery
was fixed with Patrick Ewing that was go
time for him hey Brian good luck with
everything a great job we appreciate
your time and thanks for joining us
that's Brian windhorse tspn senior NBA
writer